what do you got for me buddy
hey brent c yeah what's up rich
i don't have anything to challenge you
on because you definitely sound like you
got the game down uh i just want to know
your take on a man's body count versus a
women's body count uh
basically more so because i've always
agreed that
uh i think it's better for a man to have
a higher body count i know with women
not so much definitely because we all
know about the pair of binding issues or
whatever
but i feel like with men having a higher
body count that probably helps us
because we get a lot of experience and
stuff and like women
um
they want more seasoned guys you know
how like they go for older guys and
stuff now because i told my current girl
now that she's i met her and she's five
years younger than me and i was like
when i met her she was 21 and i was like
if you would have met 21 year old brent
you wouldn't like me so much now that
i've been through
a lot of women and got more experience
and i know what i like and know how to
deal with it properly you don't need to
spell out your notch count like i've
been through a lot of women or i've
dated right women or i've been right
like you don't need to spell it out oh
no i didn't do it with her if you just
hold out to her that you're a seasoned
gentleman and that you've done some [ __ ]
with your life she's gonna know right
right she's gonna know that you've got
experience especially if you know how to
like take care of her in the bedroom
she's gonna know that you've got some
experience right
right right like that doesn't come from
you know just waking up in the morning
and all of a sudden like you're a porn
star right let's go oh no it comes from
putting in the repetitions right so
right
as far as your notch count goes it
doesn't matter right i mean like even
when it's openly declared uh who the
hell was it gene gene simmons or
somebody um the basis from uh kiss
he married a hot ass model um i can't
remember her name but there was a there
was a reality show that they did quite a
few years ago he openly you know
declared that he slept with thousands of
women while you know while he was
touring with the band she didn't she
didn't care
oh yeah definitely they like just it
just doesn't matter to them the way that
it matters to men it matters to men
because if you're going to mate select
you don't want to have a girl that's
been [ __ ] down by the entire city
no we don't want the town
no you don't yeah that's it shannon
tweed thank you
cool okay i just wanted your opinion on
it i appreciate that all right no
problem hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you